ciao ragazzi allora sto facendo questo
video adesso ed è quasi quasi l'una di
notte del
del 9 febbraio io lo sto dicendo perché
sta succedendo un qualcosa di assurdo
cesto succede nella mente qualcosa che
non è mai successo prima su youtube
incredibile youtube sta youtube sta
morendo in questo momento preciso se c'è
qualcuno che deve defibrillare lo vi
faccio vedere perché grazie alla
segnalazione di un mio amico
praticamente c'è questo canale che sta
straripando
il counter di youtube sapete che il
contatore di degli iscritti che qui si
aggiorna in tempo reale e su questo
canale che sto stremando appunto gli
iscritti in questo momento di più di
baire lo youtube air con vestiti al
mondo bat feed video che un altro canale
grossissimo da 11 milioni di iscritti
altri youtuber famosissimi e lo stanno
filmando perché i loro iscritti in
questo momento stanno letteralmente
scomparendo tutti guardate gli skiff
lippi li fai come scende un antico dai
ne perde tipo mille ogni 20 secondi più
o meno c'è una roba incredibile è un bug
che credo sia succedendo a pochissime
persone su youtube perché se noi andiamo
adesso vi faccio vedere il sito che il
tipo usa è questo qua che si chiama live
count e se noi mettiamo che ne sono
mettiamo ipantellas ok
e questi sono gli iscritti dei punt
hellas aggiornati in tempo reale quindi
quando ipantellas guadagna nomi scritto
ecco infatti di quadri saranno presi due
perfette rendiamo su più di buy in
questo momento la radio tv che cazzo sta
succedendo
[Musica]
hayk e assurda starò basta per un
bordello di iscritti ma perché io ci sto
facendo un video su sta roba
questa cosa come potete vedere
ipantellas non succede sta succedendo a
pochissimi youtubers in tutto il mondo a
pochissimi e indovinate a chi cazzo sta
succedendo tra più di pai nomi mente
niente tana di una [ __ ] di una
[ __ ] che cazzo succede perché ne ho
preso uno no persi due
perché 92
ne ho persi 3 basta basta basta
youtube sta implodendo ragazzi giuro è
un bug incredibile io volevo andare in
live streaming questo momento è far
vedere questa cosa in live streaming e
commentarle live streaming solo che se
vado in live adesso che mezzanotte e un
quarto
non ha senso perché non c'è veramente
nessuno mi incazzo sapete sala e berline
ita scan dicono che copre più di pine io
non copio pd palco i video io lo copia
anche quando perdi iscritti ci facciamo
le cose fatte bene anche più li paga
affatto un video su sta roba da fatto
prima io ringrazio iddio di essermene
accorto perché un mio amico me la detto
mia linkato questa live qua che vi ho
fatto vedere prima dicendo mi guarda
tipo pd fire questi youtubers che stanno
perdendo un botto di iscritti poi sono
andato a vedere effettivamente era
ovvero detto mica veramente sembrano un
sacco di iscritti e poi mi è venuto in
mente ma che sto perdendo anch'io che
usava fare the reader e spaventata aiuto
grazie grazie al supporto gentilissimo
ora ragazzi visto che siamo sono io uno
dei pochi stronzi al quale sta
succedendo sta roba
in queste condizioni a power neanche
questa parte dice io e basta [ __ ]
a non è soggetto a scrivere hanno tutti
stanno cancellando tutti i siti falci
[ __ ] adesso fate tutti gli account
fake e vi iscrivete al mio canale così
importiamo su tutto su perché a buttarla
devi salire dobbiamo fare contrattacco
ma deve scendere potere agli inferi
chiamate la nonna fategli fare canale
anche allo zio e facciamo gli iscritti
forti sempre sognato di essere con voi
alla fine del mondo ragazzi e bello
essere al vostro fianco e stato un onore
essere al vostro fianco per tutto questo
periodo io sono orgoglioso di aver fatto
questo percorso con voi che se sono le
mie ultime parole prima di morire
occhio a tramp della gara la famiglia mi
servivano soprattutto una roba
incredibile ho scoperto una roba
incredibile vado che roba
questo è il corso di tecnico dice 686 no
ora io mi iscrivo al tecnico kay 687
orami disiscriversi tecnico ma persi due
come io mi iscrivo e ne guadagna uno mi
dissi scrivo per te 2
cosa facciamo perdere i siti a secco
ciao stefanino ti piace questo video
stefania lascio un bel like facciamo
perdere iscritti alla gente ipantellas
tant'è
minchia che odio jacopo ti voglio bene
denis e siete fantastici visi scritto
uno solo come no allora non funziona
raga lode ipantellas che sono immuni da
queste stregonerie di youtube bravi
ragazzi
niente ragazzi vado a dormire era solo
per capire era una news tv da uno a tre
ragazzi cercano domani
[Musica]
a dio dio
grazie grazie ragazzi grazie va a fan
culo a mentre dormivo mentre dormivo in
venuta in mente una cosa se io quando mi
sono iscritto a stefani e poi vi sono di
scritto ho fatto perdere due iscritti al
tecnico era questo il bug di youtube
youtube contava un iscritto in meno come
meno due e quindi uno si scriveva una
volta quindi il tipo guadagniamo
l'iscritto si toglieva quindi ne perdeva
2 quindi bastava che un tipo cliccasse
continuamente sui scriviti this
iscriviti scritti liszt iscriviti per
far perdere iscritti no solo allora ho
capito mentre stavo per addormentarmi
che c'era qualcuno o sul mio canale che
continuava a fare questa cosa
il ministo pezzo per pezzo di uno stanco
ma vai a dormire porca traina vabbè
comunque non
c'era la marmellata dentro c'era la
marmellata dentro quindi sta cosa in
teoria si dovrebbe essere fermata perché
adesso sono stupidi poi dovrebbe essere
a posto
beh bene quarzo contento perché se a
posto lui sono a posto anch'io ormai
youtube amici assegnati come due canali
che sono uguali quindi cosa fa lui
faccio io datemi questi 50 milioni di
iscritti in più è stato bello che mi
piacciono a me queste cose comunque la
gente che ieri all'una di notte stava
iscrivendosi iscrivendosi dal mio canale
per far perdere iscritti io dovrei stare
zitto per lo sto facendo a step in però
se siete quelli che mi scrivono che mi
devo trovare un lavoro cioè capite che
che la nostra vita è proprio una merda
però avere tanto io mi sono ripresi
marmellata tutto quindi non è un
problema
i ragazzi si è conclusa qui questa
avventura bellissima di youtube che
sbarella ringrazio youtube per rendere
il nostro lavoro molto molto molto più
movimentato e figo perché se non sarebbe
tutto molto monotono e gli heat ragazzi
concludo qui video visto che questa
avventura si è conclusa per il meglio
ringrazio chi ieri ha fatto questi click
del cazzo perché almeno mi è uscito un
video così finisci marmellata sul mio
pigiama da ragazzi